look it's a fact streamers nowadays are
basically real-life
hollywood-sized celebrities some of them
do whatever it takes bending each and
every rule to attract viewers while
others
let their gameplay do the talking
but whether you've been around since the
early days of justin tv back in 2007 or
you're just getting started you've
likely heard the term streamer pc get
thrown around from pro players to casual
content creators almost anyone who is
serious about trying to blow up on
twitch has at least considered running a
dual pc setup or a more than
dual pc setup why three pcs for content
creation versus two or one there's a
bunch of different options but what
exactly is a streaming pc and how can it
turn you into the next shroud
do you really need a fancy computer to
make it big on twitch or
is it just a luxury
[Applause]
so you wanna be a streamer eh
well aside from a fancy computer what
are you gonna need to get your channel
up and running no i'm seriously asking i
too i'm trying to get a channel up and
running in fact you can check out my
channel at twitch.tv
whoa no
no shameless plugs here but first let's
start with a single pc setup because
regardless of what your hardware specs
are you're going to need to be running
some kind of streaming software the vast
majority of streamers and content
creators use programs like xsplit and
obs for all their recording and
broadcasting you can download them for
basically any computer and operating
system but that doesn't mean that every
device is capable of running them
efficiently when it comes to streaming
video transcoding is the thing you gotta
worry about because if your computer
cannot properly transcode video then
chances are your stream is gonna end up
looking something like this yeah you
definitely don't want your stream to
look like this
so to prevent your stream from looking
like a blurry low bitrate mess there are
a couple of key components that are an
absolute must
and at the top of that list is your cpu
more powerful cpus can really help when
it comes to video encoding and
transcoding the more cores and the more
threads that the cpu has the easier it
will be to stream at higher resolutions
and even higher frame rates modern intel
i7s and amd ryzen 7s will give you
plenty of flexibility if you want a
higher quality streaming experience so
while your graphics card is busy
actually rendering the game your cpu is
handling things on the streaming side
the work of rendering the game that is
the act of actually creating the image
has already been done by your graphics
card it's then your cpu that takes that
rendered image and transcodes it into a
video format that can be easily sent
over the internet and displayed by your
viewers web browsers okay dimitri just
used a word three times there that he
almost certainly can't define clearly
transcode so let me help us all out with
a definition transcoding and encoding
are similar processes and you'll often
hear people just use the word encoding
for both but there is an important
difference erica eins gives a great
description of encoding over on
api.video as anything where the video
file contains data that comes directly
from a camera sensor transcoding is when
you take that already encoded file and
convert it into another format so your
pc is encoding your webcam and gameplay
feeds on the way into your streaming
software and then transcoding it on the
way out into a format that your
streaming platform servers can recognize
and push out to viewers now having a
powerful cpu will go a long way in the
world of streaming
but it isn't the only option anymore
streaming software like obs allows you
to use nvenk encoding rather than h.264
which lets your nvidia gpu do more of
the heavy lifting so if your gpu is a
sick new 3090 but your cpu is some
three-year-old i5 then nvenk might be
for you now we've talked a lot about
single pc setups but in the world of
content creation there are some who've
opted to go a different route some
streamers though actually decide to go a
step further and use a second pc to
handle all the streaming tasks using
their first rig strictly for actual
gaming
this can especially make sense if you
already have an older tower lying around
because it's a great way to stream
cpu-intensive games like starcraft or
total war without being concerned that
your gameplay or your stream quality
will suffer as a result the best part
about having a dedicated streaming pc is
that it doesn't need to be a maxed out
gaming rig with a ryzen 9 and a 30
whatever
hell you may not even need to put a
graphics card in it at all while one pc
focuses on actually playing the game the
secondary streaming pc only has to worry
about transcoding the video and sending
it off to your streaming service of
choice and since it's only focusing on
transcoding cpus like the ryzen 3 series
or intel's i3 and i5 models are
oftentimes more than enough despite the
fact that most of them are only
quad-core processors they're typically
able to pump out more than enough power
for transcoding on a basic streaming pc
since all you'll be running are programs
like xsplit or obs and some content
creators swear by these dual pc setups
as far as a pro player goes i don't
think any pro player has a rig like this
the whole point of a multi-computer
stream is so that your main computer can
focus all of its power on the game so i
have good fps it doesn't lag but what
made me switch to a 2p setup two pc
setup is when you're playing games you
want like the maximum frame rate
possible and when you have a one pc
setup the stress on both your cpu and
your gpu
is like
just enough
to have it
affect your stream and your game at the
same time so if you want to play at high
settings like
you can you can almost forget playing at
high settings if you want to stream it
like a high quality but aside from being
a time consuming process what exactly is
required in getting a dual pc setup up
and running
well thankfully my dear friend colton is
an absolutely feral nerd who knows all
about this stuff every time he goes live
on twitch he's running two pcs
so why do you use two of them colton and
how does it feel to be the biggest dork
in an office that writes about esports
for a living and now the guy who
actually knows what he's talking about
that's a compliment
right
i'm gonna take it as a compliment why do
i stream with two pcs
well
ah
it's because my gaming rig kinda sucks
let's be honest for the vast majority of
us we aren't raking in six figures
streaming our gaming escapades and our
gear isn't provided by sponsors we have
to work with whatever we've got for me
and for a lot of you i imagine if i
wanted to stream without compromising my
gaming experience i needed to move my
video transcoding to a separate pc now i
know what you're going to say colton
that sounds super complicated and you
aren't entirely wrong and while i may be
the guy who knows what he's talking
about i'm here to tell you that you can
definitely get your own dual pc setup up
and running way easier than you think
then you probably already have
everything you need one of the most
common pieces of hardware that comes up
in building a two pc setup is a capture
card whether you're using it to capture
video from a game console a dslr camera
or another pc they can be invaluable in
a streaming setup wow capture cards can
be a great way to get high quality video
reliably from one pc to another
especially if you have one laying around
they actually aren't the easiest at
least in my opinion so what do i
recommend as the simplest way to bridge
the gap between your two pcs it's a
handy video standard known as ndi ndi
sends the video feed over your network
and since your pcs should already be
plugged into a gigabit switch or router
and if they aren't you have bigger
problems to worry about there's no extra
cables to manage you will want to make
sure your ethernet cables are at the
bare minimum cat5e so that they can
handle the transfer speeds needed for
high quality low latency video from
there if you're using obs studio it's as
simple as downloading the free ndi
plugin from the obs website on both pcs
setting your program output from your
main pc and then adding it as a source
on your second pc if you're using
streamlabs obs head over to
obsproject.com
download obs studio and uninstall slobs
you're welcome streaming from two pcs
can make your experience both gaming and
streaming much more enjoyable and
hopefully now you've got a little more
confidence that you could set it all up
yourself i love talking about this stuff
so let me know in the comments if you
want to see some more deep dives into
streaming settings and if you want to
check out some high quality dual pc
streaming you should head over to
twitch.tv
hey whoa no uh-uh
if i can't plug neither can he and that
was the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about that said setting up a
secondary pc just for streaming isn't
for everyone
it can be a lot of work for what some
would call a minimal improvement the
setup is definitely a huge hurdle like
i've seen a few people like ammunition's
one content creator who's a dual pc
setup and she spent like i think it was
like an entire four or eight hour stream
where they were just mapping out how the
wiring would work on the dual pc setup
and like the amount of time and
dedication to put into just setting it
up for like
in my opinion minimal performance gain
isn't really worth it
and also obviously the cost factor is
you have to buy a whole separate pc to
do it with pc components becoming more
and more powerful dual pc streaming
setups have become more of a
professional or enthusiast option and
the reason for this is that many gaming
pcs are just now becoming capable of
running everything all on one machine
when it comes to streaming pcs like for
the most part as long as you have a high
end pc like i have a 3080 and an i
9 10 900 k like that's more than enough
to stream and run a game at the same
time like i'd say the only way that you
need more power is if you just have
like an insane game that's either poorly
optimized or just needs a lot of power
to run something like warzone for
example has a lot of issues like that
but most games you can run at max frame
rate and
stream and record all at the same time
on one pc things have gotten a lot
better
with like the single pc stream so i mean
a rig now compared to a couple years
a couple years ago it's completely
different but
yeah the two the two pc setup has
improved my gaming quality
like hands down
tenfold like so much better it doesn't
the game doesn't stutter
a higher quality
my stream doesn't suffer way less
dropped frames for like encoding but
yeah that's that's pretty much the
biggest
the biggest reason why i switched is my
my gameplay was just suffering because
especially with fps games like
you need those extra frames
if you're gaming at upwards of 200
frames per second in valorent or cs go
and you want to broadcast your gameplay
then chances are you'll need a pretty
powerful setup otherwise you might see
some performance dips while streaming
this is why so many current and former
cs pros have their streams set up with
two pcs they value every single frame
that they can possibly squeeze out if
you guys had to reconfigure your dual pc
you could do it on your own of course i
mean i don't have a dual pc so
look at the hell you're trolling no i'm
not dominant summit doesn't have dual pc
[Laughter]
so is a dual pc setup an absolute must
if you're looking to get into streaming
well
of course not the average gamer can
probably get away with doing everything
on one pc if their components are
powerful enough whether you want to
stream with your older hardware or
you're a hardcore competitor or content
creator who wants to max out their frame
rate or resolution both in game and on
stream
a dual pc
is absolutely worth considering if you
can swing it
you won't regret it
the whole thing with ryan is that he
swings everything like he just like he's
very good he's mechanically talented but
he's just stupid like he just
literally swings and he'll get one get
two and then to get three he'll swing
and oh look we're in a 4v3 now and
they're gonna win the round actually
right whereas if you just come back to
site we would just like guarantee the
win right if you can swing it you won't
regret it unless you're running unless
you're right
please stop swinging things ryan please
stop the swinging thing is he manies man
one's on site on the main
especially cat cam traps
please
please stop swinging cap can traps